do you have concerns about the future of
AI all the different trajectories of all
of our research yes where's your hope
where the movement has were your
concerns I'm concerned because I know we
are building a new species it has a
capability of exceeding our exceeding us
exceeding our capabilities and can breed
itself and take over the world
absolutely if you know species it is
uncontrolled we don't know the degree to
which we control it we don't even
understand what it means to be able to
control these new species so I'm
concerned I don't have anything to add
to them because it's such a great area
unknown it never happened in history
yeah the only the only time it happened
in history was evolution with human
being it was very successful was it
separately said it was a great thing for
us it was but a few people along the way
a few creatures along the way would not
agree so so it's just because it's such
a gray area there's nothing else to say
we have a sample of one sample of one
it's us but we don't let people look at
you and say yeah but we were looking to
you to help us make sure that the sample
2 works out ok we have more than samples
more we have theory of theories yeah and
that's a good we don't need to be
statisticians so sample of mine doesn't
mean me
poverty of knowledge it's not sample of
one-plus feeling conjectural theory of
what could happen that we do have but I
really feel helpless in contributing to
this argument because I know so little
in the
and my imagination is limited and I know
how much I don't know and I but I'm
concerned
you